car
[Musique]
je suis en passe elle a grand mystère de
la semaine c'est l'adieu
[Musique]
nature et caro bonsoir alors vous êtes
philosophe photographe spécialiste de
génétique cellulaire moines bouddhistes
alors je précise pour les fans des
marseillais à miami que bouddhiste ne
veut pas dire que vous buvez
à
alors moine bouddhiste mais aussi moins
médiatique vous avez vendu des centaines
de milliers de livres mais ce que
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas c'est que
les droits d'auteur sont intégralement
reversés à chaque fois à votre
organisation humanitaire qui s'appelle
karuna chez chaîne v fondée en 2000 et
qui aident aujourd'hui quatre cent mille
personnes en inde au tibet au népal dans
des écoles dans des dispensaires dans
des cliniques il vous reste rien pas
juste de quoi me déplacer ou enfin je
n'ai pas besoin mounir mitage fait neuf
mètres carrés sans chauffage j'ai pas de
voiture pas de terrain pas de maison et
puis en plus on n'est pas on va pas
faire de piscine de ses emplois les
ferrari circulent je n'ai vraiment pas
besoin ça serait plutôt des ennuis
qu'autre chose et vous
vous dites je n'ai pas de maison à part
votre petit ermitage évidemment j'ai en
tout et pour tout trois paires de
chaussures une pour ici et deux pour le
népal où je vis six mois par an voilà
c'est dénuement absolu mais non c'est la
simplicité volontaire et heureuse moine
bouddhiste mais aussi moines médiatique
on l'a dit à la télévision vous dites
c'est pour mes projets humanitaires que
je fais le clown dans les médias vous l
impression de faire le clown cher comme
des gens pas toujours le moine
hypermédiatisé vous avez dit l'homme le
plus heureux du monde c'est la plus
grosse blague de la planète enfin bon
c'est pas grave si vous voulez en fait
des fois même dire qu'il me manque
quelques pourquoi est ce que vous venez
quand vous ne mangez pas vous m'avez
demandé de venir je suis assise non je
suis tranquille dans mon ami tu as en
fait c'est très simple il ya deux
raisons une part parce qu'il ya des
idées qui me sont extrêmement chères et
qui je pense peut être utile à partager
ne serait ce sur l'altruisme la
coopération la bienveillance le fait
d'être un peu moins l'esclave de nos
toutes nos émotions destructrice et
ensuite effectivement quand je suis dans
mon nez un mitage me dis pourquoi je
redescends c'est beaucoup pour soutenir
ses projets humanitaires que j'ai
commencé dans chaplin le visage public
donc le clown et puis aussi maintenant
que je prends de l'âge l'idée peut-être
de fonder une fondation qui
malheureusement porte mon nom cg si vous
voulez que les gens continuent à donner
de l'argent il vaut mieux que le porte
si vous voulez c'est un peu une épidémie
du narcissisme et dans mon cas c'est
plutôt pour que ça ça perdure après mois
les idées sur le vers une société plus
altruiste cas peut-être des actions en
france pour ceux qui sont dans le besoin
et continuer nos actions en asie alors
voeu de pauvreté mais aussi voeu de
chasteté
alors bien sûr vous avez des aventures
amoureuses jusqu'à votre en temps vous
avez même failli vous marier comme vous
aviez 21 ans vous savez tout oui mais
depuis votre ordination en
1978 il ya donc 40 ans no sex non meyer
ceci dit c'est forcément on a des
affinités électives on se sent très
proche de certaines personnes la moitié
de l'humanité à peu près c'est des
femmes donc l'idée qu'on va dire ouh là
là attention c'est sûr qu'on a des
sentiments m'associe dit j'ai gardé
jusqu'à maintenant mais veut monastique
à 73 ans bah voila je crois que c'est
râpé le fier comme ça honnêtement ça
vous a apporté quoi cette chose de thé
alors si vous voulez c'est pas seulement
la chasteté c'est le fait que si j'avais
une famille et des enfants comme
j'aurais pu la voir je serais
probablement encore ainsi pasteur aucune
n'est pas l'idée de partir dans
l'himalaya pendant cinq ans tout seul
dans un ermitage comme je lé fais au fil
du temps c'est pas très sympa pour la
femme et les enfants bon donc si vous
venez ça donne une liberté incroyable
j'aurais jamais pu faire tout ce que
j'ai fait pendant 50 ans dans l'himalaya
si j'avais eu la responsabilité d'une
famille élever des enfants l'incroyable
quand même matière higuain c'est que les
maîtres et les lamas bouddhiste n'ont
pas d'obligation de chasteté enfermé
deux mètres principaux les premiers
kangoo y aurait un beau chèque de 15 mo
j avais une famille c'était le yogi
alors je n'ai pas fait ce voeu de
monastique comme le dal et la malle l'a
fait par exemple c'est un choix de vie
un choix de l'obligatoire des savons ça
vous n'êtes pas forcément d'atteindre à
l'éveil simplement ça simplifie
d'existence pour sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous dites la droite a fini par
apparaître comme un syndicat de défense
des privilégiés il faut que la droite se
consacre aux déshérités avant tout moi
je prendrais un exemple tout simple je
reviens à la réalité de mon expérience
d'enseignant c'est vraiment ma vocation
j'ai toujours voulu en signant le
secondaire et quand j'ai commencé à
enseigner j'ai été au contact de ceux
qui sont directement les principales
victimes de la crise de notre école
quand la droite a défendu une opposition
très forte aux questions éducatives aux
réformes qui avait lieu elle le faisait
souvent en disant il faut défendre
l'excellence il faut défendre l'élitisme
c'est vrai d'une certaine manière qu'il
faut défendre l'excellence mais il faut
d'abord défendre l'excellence non pas
pour ceux qui sont déjà les plus
favorisés faut d'abord la défendre pour
ceux qui sont directement victimes de la
baisse du niveau dans notre école
souffre aujourd'hui c'est à dire de ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui dans les familles
qui cumule le plus de difficultés ça
c'est un grand thème de la droite
défendent la culture défendre la
transmission d'un héritage mais nous
devons défendre ces questions là d'abord
pour les plus déshérités et pour les
plus défavorisés
alors
que l'intellectuel et du culturel sur
l'économie et préférer la lettre aux
chiffres et sa gare mohammadi ici que
effectivement le monde avait basculé le
jour où les chiffres ont pris le pouvoir
c'est vrai qu'on vit cet aboutissement
aujourd'hui qu'est la numérisation du
monde où tout ce qui existe doit pouvoir
être traduit en chiffres ou tout ce
qu'on vit doit pouvoir être convertis en
nombre cette numérisation du monde cette
passion pour le big data dette elle nous
laisse un peu démuni quand il s'agit de
dire ce qui ne se traduit pas en nombre
et je crois que je vais pas donner le
sentiment que je suis opposé au nombre
que je suis opposé à la liberté
d'entreprendre à l'initiative à la
réussite économique c'est très important
encore une fois mais de fait il faut
qu'il ya un marché il faut qu'ils aient
un marché qui fonctionne bien mais ce
qui donne un sens au marché ce qui donne
un sens au chiffre est allé change c'est
ce qui ne s'échangent pas c'est ce qui
ne se marchande pas alors vous attendez
quoi du grand débat national françois
xavier bellamy je sais pas trop quoi en
attente parce qu'on fait ce qui me fait
très peur c'est le sentiment qu'on ne
sait pas du tout à quoi il va finir par
servir la politique c'est aussi d'aider
des rythmes qui sont déterminés par les
institutions je le disais tout à l'heure
je pense qu'on paye assez cher le fait
que le débat de 2017 n'a pas été pour la
france l'occasion d'un vrai choix
d'avenir et du coup aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec toutes ces questions qu'on
n'a pas réglé en fais sans doute on ne
fera pas l'économie de retourner
ensemble au moment de ce choix parce que
si c'est juste un débat en l'air je sais
pas tellement ce que le président de la
république pourra faire des résultats
qui lui seront confiées si vous étiez au
pouvoir
est-ce que vous reviendriez sur le
mariage pour tous
si j'étais au pouvoir je pense qu'il
vrai qu'on repense en profondeur la
question de la famille c'est ça qui m'a
beaucoup blessée dans ce débat c'est que
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas réussi à
se comprendre au fond qu'on n'a pas
réussi à en parler vraiment ça a été une
occasion de confrontation très vive très
dur et très dur et d'une certaine
manière très blessantes pour tout le
monde
dans ce débat moi ce qui me tenait à
coeur c'est de dire justement que dans
ce monde où tout est mouvant on a besoin
de repères clairs et stable et que être
un enfant ça veut dire savoir qui sont
ses parents et qu'on peut pas faire du
seul désir l'occasion du lien de
filiation si on fait du seul désir
l'occasion du lien de filiation
annonçait la fragilité du désir et en
disant ça je parle pas spécialement de
la question de l'homosexualité ou des
personnes homosexuelles c'est une
question qui évidemment portée et peser
sur elle mais d'une certaine façon ce
n'est pas d'abord le sujet le sujet
fondamental c'est qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une famille et ça fait trop longtemps
vraiment qu'on est en train de
détricoter par tous les moyens possibles
je pense à la politique familiale en
particulier qu'on est en train de
détricoter ce qui faisait une des forces
de notre pays c'est à dire le fait qu'il
se reposait qu'il s'appuyait sur la
solidité des liens familiaux c'est un
grand un penser d'ailleurs de la
question des gilets jaunes aujourd'hui
sur les ronds points les gens disent
d'abord qu'ils sont tous seuls dans
cette solitude cette solitude profonde
qu'on est tous exposés à vivre
aujourd'hui elle est aussi liée à la
question de la famille si j'étais au
pouvoir je tenterai ou en tous les cas
si demain je fais de la politique je
tenterai simplement d'essayer de reposer
cette question de savoir ce que c'est
que ce lien fondamental qui nourrit
alors si vous étiez au pouvoir est-ce
que vous soyez plus restrictive sur
l'accueil des migrants
oui parce que je pense qu'en fait une
politique qui prétend à la belle
intention de l'ouverture
inconditionnelle provoque exactement la
catastrophe qu'elle dénonce
fondamentalement tout ce qui augmente
les flux tout ce qui fait comme si on
pouvait croire qu'il y a des migrants
c'est un travers ce mot de migrants
personne n'est un migrant en fait
personne n'est en déplacement on est
tous justement des êtres humains on a
tous besoin d'une demeure et tout
migrant qui est arrachée à son univers
familier à sa demeure soit par la
violence du lieu où ils se trouvent soit
par le fait qu un eldorado la tire qui
est en fait une utopie une fiction tout
migrant qui est arrachée à son milieu
naturel vie d'abord un arrachement il
est perdu est perdu il perd quelque
chose de fondamental et en fait quand
vous quand on fait comme si on pouvait
venir ici sans condition quand on fait
comme si c'était facile de s'installer
dans notre pays on provoque la tragédie
j'ai lu un rapport passionnant et
quelques jours qui dit que c'est des
chercheurs européens qui ont travaillé
sur le sujet que le business des
passeurs s'alimente de la fragilité des
procédures d'asile et le business des
passeurs on sait ce que c'est de la
traite d'êtres humains avec évidemment
les plus belles promesses et qui se
nourrit de nos belles intentions et donc
il faut qu'on soit capable de dire
'voilà construire une demeure c'est à
dire avoir quatre murs et une porte
c'est la condition pour accueillir ceux
qui en ont vraiment besoin mais c'est
aussi ce qui doit nous permettre de
faire en sorte qu'on retourne à un monde
qui soit un peu plus sensée où on ne
facilite pas indéfiniment les
circulations qui provoque du malheur à
grande échelle pourtant françois que cd
bellamy la charité chrétienne vous
imposerez quand même de recevoir ces
gens qui souffrent dans leur pays n'ont
bien sûr il faut il faut ouvrir la porte
à ceux qui en ont besoin à ceux qui en
ont absolument besoin mais je dirais de
choses sur le sujet la première chose
c'est que aujourd'hui ceux qui viennent
dans notre pays sont ceux qui ont réussi
à réunir dans leur pays suffisamment
d'économies suffisamment de moyens pour
partir ceux qui ont quelques formations
quelques diplômes et donc en fait
derrière là aussi nos bonnes intentions
appauvrissez t il il y a évidemment ce
qui vient empêcher ces pays de se
développer comme il le devrait la
deuxième chose qui est très important
aussi c'est qu'en réalité l'asile ça
suppose de pouvoir aller dans un pays
sûr quand votre pays est traversé par la
guerre ou par la violence quand vous
êtes dans un village et que votre maison
brûle c'est normal que vous puissiez
être accueillis chez votre voisin parce
que vous en avez besoin mais quand vous
êtes dans un village et que votre maison
brûle vous avez pas nécessairement le
droit d'entrer dans n'importe quelle
maison du village
aujourd'hui on est tombé dans une sorte
de folie avec la question de l'asile on
fait comme si parce que votre pays ne va
pas bien vous avez le droit d'habiter
dans le monde entier là où vous en avez
envie
pour vous amour et mariage
ne coïncident pas forcément
pas plus que amour et sexe mais non bien
entendu
enfin si encore faut-il que c'est à dire
mais tout ça est dans une confusion que
que vous pouvez voir partout aussi les
bas dans les kiosques les magazines
c'est à dire non c'est une confusion
complète je crois que tout simplement
l'amour est quelque chose de tout à fait
profond qui est qui en train d'une
fidélité très profondes qui n'a rien du
tout sexuel voilà n'a rien à voir vous
dites la fidélité sexuelle c'est idiot
oui oui c'est pas la vraie fidélité non
voilà et en même temps la sexualité est
bien sens mieux puisque vous dites la
sexualité des jeunes jour n'est pas
pauvre elle est inexistante et vous vous
expliquer en avant du moment où tout est
permis à plus rien et drôle quoi il ya
plus de tabous il ya plus transgression
en fait est bon et c'est pour ça qu'il
ya des pressions voilà alors son mariage
pour tous on vous a demandé votre avis
vous avez dit le mariage qu'il soit
hétéro ou gay est un abêtissement
voilà alors à propos de balance
t'emporte vous avez dit c'est injuste
pour les corps car le port est une
créature éminemment érotique oui et est
douce et tendre et et bram non plus bien
que ce soit interdit vous savez dans
certaines régions
religieuse le port le port mais c'est
pousser telle merveille le port arrivé à
bon port oui
c'est un point fondamental
c'est pas dans vos clips mais vous
l'avez dit sur france inter il ya deux
ans la femme française a baissé depuis
le xviiie siècle est ce que vous pensez
que balances ton port a tué le
libertinage par exemple ça ne peut pas
que tuer la liberté note que le
libertinage
correspondre à des des systèmes nerveux
qui se débrouilleront dans n'importe
quelle circonstance n'importe quoi donc
c'est à tout simplement des trucs qui
sont ce qu'ils sont de vengeance de
ressentiment le problème aujourd'hui
c'est la haine vous savez c'est la haine
vous tuer et tu haïras ton prochain
comme toi même voilà où nous en
parler de dieu donc j'ai taté on est
d'accord vous êtes athée mais vous êtes
quand même sensible à lançant aux orgues
j'aime l'église catho et je suis ahuri
de voir qu'elle est en pleine
détérioration
confessons procès sans arrêt sexuelle et
que tout ça je suis beaucoup déclaré
azam jésuites qui qui lutte contre sa
curie et qu'il enferme qu'il veut lui
coupe les jarrets à chaque occasion tout
ça est triste mais très révélateur parce
que c'est sûr de bilan ça se fasse et
quand vous êtes en italie ce cher
thierry ardisson vous admirez quoi
l'église voilà c'est merveilleux
réalisation en revanche ballet du diable
pour vous le diable c'est la société du
spectacle c'est le mensonge social c'est
quelqu'un qui s'affiche très moral
moraliste ont tous les cas et vous tenez
par rapport à se moralise ou à cette
moraline à conserver votre mauvaise
réputation oui absolument et d'ailleurs
je la conserve très bien je suis censuré
à peu près partout merci de ma vie
traiter
le dr le diable c'est le prince de ce
monde c'est à dire le président manceau
suit les textes soldats ces prêts et
c'est quelqu'un qui veut diviser pour
régner alors j'adore quand vous dites il
n'est pas question que je meurs c'est
génial ce fait
j'adore bien sûr
il ya un philosophe que j'aime beaucoup
qui spinoza et qui a écrit ceci nous
sentons et nous expérimentons que nous
sommes éternels et ben voilà bah voilà
j'expérimente
il ya peut-être une chose dont j'ai
parlé à ma femme intérieur c'est la
question que l'on bros
[Musique]
les déclarer aucun des écrivains que
j'admire n'est à l'académie elle est
réservée aux médiocres à ce qu'ils ne
laisseront pas de traces durables tassée
en 2008 dix ans après vous n'avez pas
changé d'avis non pas du tout la du
chrtr je pense que c'est en pleine
perdition d'ailleurs les écrivains
intéressante ce qui pourrait produire un
petit soubresaut sait si houellebecq
venant de sa misère rentré à la calibrer
ce serait un pied de nez mais ce serait
une plaisanterie magnifique donc nom par
nom comme quand vous voyez frédéric
mitterrand pascal bruckner luc ferry se
faire recaler ça vous désole où sont pas
des écrivains mais en principe il y
avait des gens oseraient de très grand
talent à l'académie mauriac pas le nom
renvoie la pareille
là ça n'est plus ça toujours été
assez triste comme comme personnel bon
en fait je sais pas pourquoi on parlait
encore de ce vieux miroir oui c'est un
miroir d'un mois
et maintenant la main qu'on va faire une
interview meilleur ennemi
quel est le pire défaut des manuels
macro d'être aux jeunes qu'est-ce que
vous enviez à laurent wauquiez rien
si d'ailleurs réussi la performance de
montrer que la plus grande d éducation
ne n'est pas synonyme d'intelligence
politique
qu'est ce qui est rassurant jeu marine
le pen rien
qu'est ce qui est admirable chez
ségolène royal sa ténacité oui qu'est-ce
qui vous rend dingue de benoît hamon
qui
qu'est ce qui rend christophe castaner
si exceptionnel d'être là où il est
qu'est-ce qui si impressionnant chez
marie ne sera pas le fait qu'elle arrive
vous faire parler d'elle tout le temps
ouais elle se donne du mal quand même
mais vous aimez vous tombez dans pièges
avaient volontiers volontiers qu'est ce
que françois hollande avait compris
avant les autres
rien
qu'est ce que l'on regrette chez nicolas
sarkozy
que les pas de côté qu'il a pu faire
font qu'on ne garde pas le meilleur
souvenir de ce qu'il a fait de bien ce
dont on a parlé qu'est-ce qui est
craquant sur de la merkel sa fermeté son
courage
moi elle m'a précieuse beaucoup et elle
me fait craquer désolé
quelle est la plus grande expression de
sagesse de donald points il y en aura
peut-être une ne pas se représenter
voilà en fait donald trump c'est un peu
le président d gilet jaune américain non
c'est pour ça qu'il vaut mieux que les j
ai je n'ai pas le pouvoir ce que j'aime
dans vos interviews c'est ça me rappelle
le grand oral de l'ena mais en rigolo
vous raconter les années charlie hebdo
donc effectivement ce passionnant elle
pas tout dire aujourd'hui mais c'est
vraiment passionnant les années france
inter alors là aussi ça recommence on
dit que c'est l'amitié vous avec carla
bruni qu'elle va inciter nicolas sarkozy
à vous faire nommer à la tête de la
station ça a été un mais si les gens si
les gens avaient été un peu observateur
et il aurait compris quand même que je
travaillais avec jean luc hess depuis
déjà 20 ans synergie on travaille est un
vraiment ensemble depuis longtemps on a
même dit que vous écriviez les chansons
de carla bruni avec whisky étaient
insultants pour carla c'est vrai car là
est une amie et que j'aime beaucoup et
et qui écrit des très belles chansons
tout seul elle a tellement pas besoin de
moi pour écrire ses chansons c'est c'est
pas faire confiance aux femmes un fond
que de dire ça et de préciser qu en plus
j'étais on était amis carla et moi avant
qu'elle ne connaisse le président de la
république
[Musique]
tu mises en cause quelqu'un qui m'a dit
alors en tout cas nicolas sarkozy vous
avez des conseillers de virer guillon ça
c'est vrai c'est dingue parce que les
cinq ans où j'ai été patron de france
inter les gens croyaient que je prendrai
mes ordres à l'elysée mais c'était
délirant ce qui m'a jamais parlé de
france inter la seule fois où on a parlé
il m'a dit mais tu es con de virer
guillon c'est que des emmerdes mais
voilà non j mais je suis obligé de le
faire parce que comme ils m'insultent
tous les matins à pratiquement jeu
pouvait plus gouverner la chaîne c'était
possible c'est comme quand on a une
classe de gosse et qui en a un qui
voudraient de salles contre pauvres
contre tous les matins tous les jours
vous pouvez pu obtenir votre place on
regarde cers j'ai entendu ici et là que
mon départ serait une décision politique
si c'est politique c'est stupide que je
sois ou pas présent sur cette antenne le
président dévisse je n'ai aucune
incidence ça ne peut pas être politique
c'est vrai qu'après mon papier sur dsk
et martine aubry le président sarkozy a
dit dans un avion qu'il détestait mon
travail quelques mois plus tard il nomme
à france inter un ami de carlita
philippe val auteur de cette phrase
désormais culte france inter est une
radio qui coûte cher à l'actionnaire qui
n'est pourtant pas très bien traité par
la station
guillon quoi mais l'actionnaire c'est le
peuple ouais donc je sens quand on dit
ça tous les matins le peuple est
maltraité parce qu'il ya toute une
partie qui paye pas pour entendre ça
ouais voilà donc pour moi il n'était pas
drôle enfin c'était pas drôle ce truc là
il a déçu il a du talent il a une
présence et tout ça mais mais c'est pas
quelqu'un de deux nuls mais mais c'était
pas bon quoi dois je crois surtout qu'
il aime bien se faire virer pourquoi si
quelqu'un avec vous c'était le cas avec
mais depuis c'est un jeu de marionnettes
il cherche à louer ou maxi oui je pense
que c'était vraiment voulu de sa part
jusqu'à ce qu'ils prennent une claque en
quittant france inter vous écrivez à vos
collaborateurs
j'ai une pensée émue pour ceux qui ont
aimé me détester
oui parce que c'est un milieu moutonnier
que c'est facile c'est comme les gens
qu'on va sacs vuitton dans les aéroports
et qui se reconnaissent entre eux un
petit signe donc de me détester c'était
un signe de ralliement oui je comprends
ça moi comprend tout ça c'est pas un
problème il vous raconter votre vie
aujourd'hui
vous êtes aussi protégé qu'un magasin
huit ans un samedi de gilet jaune
absolument oui
normal sur icar on va voir si vous savez
rester zen en toutes circonstances on va
faire un stress tests
alors quand quelqu'un passe devant vous
dans une file d'attenté est ce que vous
arrivez à garder votre calme oui ça va
votre jour j'ai traversé en dehors des
clous ya un climat dirait dégage bouddha
imaginons le point l'avion il ya un
enfant qui était assis derrière vous et
il donne des coups de pieds dans le
dossier de votre siège malheureusement
sont assez épais pour d'accord vous
avons fait avec et quand un chauffeur de
taxi à paris vous oblige à écouter les
grosses têtes pendant tout le voyage non
mais sur tripoli en fait il vous
demandez moi je dit écoutez moi ça me
dérange pas alors je reste tranquille si
vous voulez l'écouter d'accord vous
regardez des films j'avais 40 ans je
n'ai pas été dans as un rôle de cinéma
mais je regrette 30 ans à la télévision
quand la publicité arrivent au moment où
on va connaître le nom du meurtrier est
ce que ça vous stresse et pas on regarde
pas des films où tout le monde sans
trois dit la mère mais c'est vrai que la
publicité en gros c'est faut faire
hacher des 3es pas besoin donc moi quand
j'ai besoin de quelque chose je sais
très bien ce que je veux donc c'est pas
besoin de la pub
[Musique]
imaginons que vous soyez au bord de la
mer et le soir vous vous couchez il ya
du sable dans vos draps ouais c'est pas
un problème tant que ça rentre pas dans
mon appareil de photo ça va d'accord
quand quelqu'un fait craquer ses doigts
comme ça devant bull a
pas de problème ça vous énerve pas non
je vous exercez un recommandé à la poste
lorsque vous arrivez à garder votre
calme
non mais c'est un peu agaçant quand des
courriers services live au design on n'a
pas trouvé votre maison faut venir ça 40
km quand vous commandez un dîner chinois
chez des libéraux et que le livreur a
oublié les baguettes à écouter en inde
en manger avec ses doigts mais ça m'est
jamais arrivé donc je sais pas quand on
vous demande si le prénom du dalaï lama
c'est dallas et ça vous énerve ce n'est
pas arrivé y'a quoi pour imaginer ça
d'accord quand vous devez participer à
une conférence et que votre robe n'est
pas repassé ne l'est jamais elle jamais
repasser sa marraine d'une fois tous les
trois ans un bon d'accord vous quand on
vous fait des blagues sur votre tenue
la profession ni froid et enfin à mon
avis c'est le pire quand vous vous tapez
le petit orteil contre un pied de lui
est ce que ça vous gave
bon ça fait mal c'est tout ouais vous
mettez pas en colère vous arrivez à
avoir la peau trop qui en plus est
l'icône librement ça sera un peu bas il
est bien
et suit jackson diane watts et lanvin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non elle à 50 balais elle à tomber par
terre seulement qu'il avoit faut pas que
tu reste bloqué sur un schéma de
gonzesses pardon
ça va très bien alors tu sais que tu es
dans sérotonine le succès de michel
houellebecq on m'a dit oui en fait le
narrateur dans le livre regarde à la
télé une émission hommage à laurent
baffie c'est un peu comme si tu étais
mort ah bah oui cette émission là était
à géographique ses lecteurs les jeux des
potes qu'on s'appelle on dit mais tu es
mort non non tout va bien là lui l'a cru
que c'était bon alors cette polyphonie
bien orchestrée par le montage
conduisait une vraie relecture du
travail de laurent baffie et s'achever
de manière symphonique par la reprise
quasi chorale d'une expression qui
faisait l'unanimité des intervenants
laurent été par quelque bout qu'on le
prenne une belle personne
alors merci mais juste préciser quand il
écrit que par quelque bout qu'on le
prenne c'est une figure de rhétorique
non mais ça c'est clair surtout dans la
lancée par quelque bout qu'on le prix
oui exactement comme dieu alors est ce
que tu sais que dans plateforme michel
houellebecq avait prévu les attentats de
bali oui est ce que tu sais que
soumission est sorti le jour des
attentats de charlie wi alors dans ces
autos nine quand même michel houellebecq
avait vu les gilet jaune il est prévu
les légines et jaune et dans le même
bouquin il annonce sa mort non pas du
tout il dit en regardant j'ai cru que
leur fils était mort mais que nenni que
je point va pas me porter lâche conran
manade dénombre encore
comment on a quand même un peu en effet
et alors wayne bebb parle dont on sait
pas très bien quand c'est ce situe il
parle d'une année où le 24 décembre
tombe un dimanche donc qui on a cherché
évidemment tu payes la rédaction je vais
mourir un dimanche n'ont pas autre chose
à ma mère ils vont portefeuille l'année
où le 24 décembre tombe un dimanche donc
l'année où j'ai laissé dans quatre ans
mais ça me concerne pas parce que c'est
pas c'est pas il a 24 ans et ça me
concerne pas 4 vous transformez
l'écrivain du crépuscule ou madame
soleil ouais
c'est l'heure des récompenses qui
peuvent faire mal très mal c'est là deux
mois tu dors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un coup de folie mais un coup de folie
laurent le coup de folie de netflix
alors enrico macias et valérie damidot
starsky hutch ça se dit mieux quand même
enrico lui je considère qu'il est culte
j'adore enrico il a toujours été là il
est à lui tout seul la preuve vivante
que le transhumanisme n'est peut-être
pas une chimère lorsque les tortues
marines et enrico macias sont les deux
espèces répertoriées pour l'instant pour
notre plus grand bonheur laurent qui
contiennent le secret de la vie
éternelle alors valérie damidot thierry
c'est un peu plus compliqué je ne savais
même pas qu'elle existât
j'ai appris son existence la semaine
dernière dans un entretien où elle
disait que j'étais affublé d'un
appendice reproducteurs que la tombola
génétique à 38 ans cette portion
pourtant stratégique dans mon adaptation
avait rendu proche en taille de celle du
surmulot dans le langage dali d'eau ou
la monosyllabes tient lieu de
dictionnaires ça donne il a un petit
kiki une telle élévation de penser à
lier un sens si rare de la répartie
c'est la noblesse du pays de mahler de
la bruyère et de boileau autant de noms
que valérie damidot ira sans doute
vérifiez dans les rayonnages de
conforama dans la bibliothèque de
valérie damidot ou l'intégrale de
fantômes est relié plein pot et rangée
dans la section philosophie aux côtés de
50 nuance degrés on ne trouve aucun mes
livres aucun et c'est pour cela que
j'écris thiery pour ne pas être lue par
valérie damidot mais passons admettons
que pour une raison ou une autre après
tout j'ai commis un crime qu elles
soient fâchés pour ça enrico lui n'a
rien fait ni rien du tout à part
peut-être éventuellement fumer de la
marijuana avec les types de chez netflix
le prince saoud al faysal d'arabie
saoudite cousin de mohamed ben salman
aurait commandé il est mort en 2000
15000 aurait commandé pour 90 mille
euros de films x sur mesure c'est là que
tout commence sur mesure à une société
française et il est mort avant de payer
la note alors aujourd'hui ses filles se
retrouvent avec cet héritage payer 90
mille euros de porno fait sur mesure
alors thiery en prono tout existe il ya
tout il ya luro le scato le cateau le
germano le gilet jaune au maintenant
d'ailleurs
c'est vrai c'est vrai le zoo le [ __ ]
leva ginola nallo le bol chaud le facho
le latino l'homo l'hétéro le raciale au
le crado le féticheur le playmobil au
lardy sono le maso le sado le laurent
baffo le neuf en tout existe bien le
type n'avait pas trouvé son compte il
fallait alors qu'une nouvelle catégorie
cher laurent cher thierry je vous
propose une chose on se cotise 30000
euros chacun et on va regarder ce qui se
passe à new
works d'or du rire jaune à gad elmaleh
alors gagner de mal et il accuse une
nouvelle fois de plagiat il a plagié des
humoristes américains comme georges
carline martin knight ou des humoristes
français d'ailleurs comme dany boon ou
donel jack'sman alors faire rire avec
l'humour d'autrui c'est un peu comme se
faire jouir avec le sexe d'un autre
c'est quand même
c'est un manque de respect non pas par
le pour le public le public lui s'en
fiche on lui donne hariri c'est pas mon
de respect pour le plagier pour le
pelage et c'est un honneur et non c'est
un manque de respect pour soi même dire
que c'est reconnaître tout d'un coup
qu'on ait rien du tout et que l'autre et
tout finalement le plagiat c'est la
jalousie plus le vol l'impuissance plus
la dignité la paresse plus le mensonge
mais le plagiaire finit toujours par
croire que ce qu'il a volé de lui c'est
certain que j'ai souvent remarqué eric
clapton a tenté de se hisser jusqu'à
bbking lui c'était quand même quelque
chose de louables gad elmaleh lui a fait
les poches de dany boon c'est autre
chose mais gad elmaleh il reste quand
même un génie thierry parce qu'il
parvient de faire rire que lui-même avec
l'humour des autres waouh
ça fait mal
et on commence et que jean michel
blanquer on a fait une belle ministre de
l'éducation nationale j'ai rien contre
lui il est plutôt simple un bon ben il
est descendu à dreux et puis rigole pas
ce qu'il faut mais alors là il a laissé
passer dans une itt de livres commandés
par l'éducation nationale un manga où il
est question d'une sorcière qui je cite
aspire à zizi qui le sucer en disant que
c'est bon un manga qui est recommandé
par l'éducation nationale pour les
enfants entre 9 et 11 ans jean-michel
alors moi au même âge thierry je lisais
le petit chose d'alphonse daudet qui
tirait le diable par la queue dont je
demande s'était pas cryptés alors je
réclame désormais deux choses d'abord le
marquis de sade à l'agrégation la lettre
et que katsumi en place bancaire
j'ai commencé par un max d'or au cyber
connard de la ligue du lol la ligue du
lol c'est quoi ces des journalistes ou
des journalistes traitement envoyer des
tweets à tout le monde notamment à des
jeunes femmes ou à des homosexuels pour
les contrôler pour les chambres et pour
les trolls et mais alors une fois c'est
drôle si vous les deux fois c'est moins
drôle trois fois c'est pas drôle du tout
mais ils ont fait des centaines de fois
ici une sorte d'élite autoproclamé
d'internet qui a commencé à filtrer tous
les toute l'airé d'accueil il y avait
des gens comme vincent glad par exemple
des gens qui étaient assez connu vincent
glad des gens des inrocks de télérama
rasad des gens qui nous donnent toute la
journée des leçons de morale en plus oui
vous savez j'avais dit il ya quelques
semaines qu'on était en trop l'ocrha si
c'est dire qu'en fait il ya des abrutis
qui nous harcèlent toute la journée et
qui font un peu la loi sur internet
alors le lol déjà ça m'a jamais fait
rire moi le lol c'est un truc c'est
comme des applaudissements enregistrés
dans l'est dans l'est dans les sites
comme ça gâche un peu le plaisir et la
france j'ai l'impression est devenue une
cour de récré géante on harcèle comme
dans les cours de récré des petites
filles alors il ya un pauvre imbécile du
nom d'henri michel qui a dit cet endroit
réunissez parmi les plus grands talents
de twitter alors henri michel oui tu es
un pauvre abruti mon vieux car
précisément twitter a été inventé pour
les gens comme toi qui n'ont aucun
talent alors oui parce que il faut quand
même le répéter ça je le martèle ray
jusqu'à la fin
twitter c'est une benne à ordures c'est
une fosse septique et même parfois une
fausse aseptique puisqu'on sait que les
révisionnistes adore twitter c'est un
dépotoir twitter c'est une déchetterie
c'est un égout les membres de la ligue
du lol se présentent comme des
personnalités sortant du lot alors moi
cette autoproclamation de la supériorité
thiery et laurent ça me fait vraiment
vomir il ya des génies incompris eux ce
sont d incompréhensible rapt et sortait
du lot si vous voulez les gars mais s'il
vous plaît sortait également de nos vies
retournez dans le néant l'oubli vous va
si bien et ne vous inquiétez pas pour
l'avenir la médiocrité peut à elle seule
occupé combler toute une vie
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais donner un mois de l'or à
l'époque thiriez a moix d'or de la
médiocrité de l'époque ça pleutrerie
jean marie bigard a fait un sketch et
cyril hanouna ni la wii enfin une petite
blague l'arc d'une blague sur notamment
il a animé une sorte de viol une scène
de viol qui se passait chez le médecin
alors on sait que l'humanité a perdu 10
points de clients sans en tirer mais ça
se voit pas ce que est ce qu'on a oublié
la fonction de l'humour l'humour a pour
fonction de s'emparer de la réalité de
la dire avec son langage de la tordre
dans tous les sens et il ne peut pas y
avoir d'humour choquant ça n'existe pas
l'humour choquant pour une raison simple
c'est que c'est une tautologie l'humour
doit être choquant l'humour doit dépaysé
il doit étonner il doit surprendre il
doit choquer et c'est pas la blague de
jean marie bigard qui devrait nous
surprendre nous étonner nous dégoûter
c'est le viol qui devrait nous
surprendre nous dégoûter et nous
survolté et nous mettre en colère et
donc je voudrais défendre jean marie
parce que moi c'est le viol que je
déteste et non pas jean marie bigard et
ses blagues sur le viol quand chaplin
incarne charlot il parle de la pauvreté
aujourd'hui ils auraient tous les sdf
dans la rue mézy sont déjà donc ça tombe
bien qui dirait c'est dégueulasse il se
moque des pauvres chaplin ne pourrait
plus faire charlot aujourd'hui il faut
le faire faut le voir pourrait plus
faire coller rien donc un humoriste à
six risques et périls bien sûr c'est ce
qu'il veut l'humour choc en ligue liste
parce qu'ils existent l humour raté
c'est ça qui est pire car l'humour comme
la boxe une histoire ça ne supporte pas
l'à peu près reprocher à jean marie
bigard d'être vulgaire c'est comme
reproché à marcel proust d'utiliser des
imparfait du subjonctif ça n'a aucun
sens 20 et j'aurai aussi précisé que le
verbe [ __ ] est un très joli verbe
c'est un très joli mot [ __ ] on le
retrouve chez le marquis de sade c'est
georges bataille donc les indignés
perpétuelle commence vraiment mais
vraiment on est vraiment comme disait
desproges à nous escagasser le bas de
l'oreille interne des proches qui
pensait lui aussi qu'un homme seul et
vulgaire vaut mieux qu'une neutre
nombreuses et débile alors vive les
enculage vivent les [ __ ] sûrs vive les
[ __ ] ri j'ai bien des foyers la
terrine en parfait gré parfait
et voilà on commence avec un flux tout
le monde joue à certaines le biopic oui
[Musique]
auj
alors je vous donne un acteur ou une
actrice et vous me donnez la célébrité
qu'il ou elle a incarné au cinéma mais
tu sais pas j'ai pas une aussi bonne
culture cinéma ne vous inquiétez pas
marion cotillard berdyev
montois
particules est faux de près eric
elmosnino gainsbourg gainsbourg et deux
sans toi
françois xavier demaison oui non
il faut que les points
0 amy mc
oui alors c'est au revoir là où on est
du même avis
freddie mercury
vincent cassel google pas que google
mesrine les deux sont morts
attention salma hayek
et davina qu'elle aura à lacanau si la
dépendance
simple
lambert wilson ne s'intéresse pas aux
biopics sépare les autres acteurs
jacques dutronc bon gars non non non moi
il vaut
bien mieux
qu'elles font un
jamie foxx
[Applaudissements]
j'abandonne sur moi quand tu te remonte
la barre jérémie rénier plâtre en soi
attention
meryl streep me thatcher
il ya un suspense michel bouquet
mitterrand oui oui
forest whitaker
jamel debbouze non non c'est un un
dirigeant africain a prôné la non non
non non il est gens méchants amin dada
oui où
attention c'est égalité entre laurent
baffie et jérôme commandeur et il en
restera et donc c'est là que tout va se
jouer on se concentre le gagnant aura
droit en bref la bible robeez la bombe
devait servir la bise sur ma joue à moi
voilà à la serre dépend attention pierre
niney salon
alors
[Applaudissements]
tant qu'elle est maintenant on continue
avec shopping la promo qui s'affiche
arielle dombasle rebonds sont
alors jetés ici ce soir lauriane pour
nous parler de alien crystal palace
votre quatrième long métrage alors avec
vous il ya donc asia argenteau michel
fau grands acteurs
christian louboutin notre ami christian
louboutin et nicolas cayre hélas
accrochez vous je fais le pitch
c'est l'histoire d'un savant fou à la
tête d'une set qui organise un faux
tournages de films pour provoquer la
rencontre entre une réalisatrice à
lamballe est un repère nicolas cayre
car il les juge suffisamment
différent est compatible pour recréer le
mythe antique de l'androgyne de platon
ce mythe raconte que les humains à
l'origine étaient des êtres complet qui
ont été coupées en deux et donc qu'ils
sont condamnés à chercher leur moitié
d'orange c'est pour ça que c'est bien ça
oui exactement 6 et en même temps ce
chef de secte qui enfin de secte il a
pris la place de meetic grinder timber
c'est quelqu'un d'une de la wii oui
quelqu'un qui croit savoir mieux que
nous même les objets du désir qui croit
savoir mieux que nous-mêmes qui sera la
personne idéale alors c'est l'histoire
de dolores rivers donc est une cinéaste
d'inde à g et de nicolas atlante qui est
un chanteur de rock vénéneux
mais le diable va s'en mêler oui le
diable va s'en mêler car qu'est ce que
c'est que le diable finalement aussi
c'est notre inconscient dont nous ne
sommes pas maîtres mais voilà les
inconscients ont leur mot à dire voilà
et voilà tout commence alors moi j'ai vu
le film je dire soit vous remportez un
césar soit vous êtes interné en fait
alors est-ce que le lsd fourni
avec la place de cinéma oui
tu peux venir est ce qu'il faut mais
c'est très peu haché et être avec son
propre et lisse les cheveux non mais
mais il est vrai que que je suis
entourée de beaucoup d'artistes qui sont
à à ses
percées oui mais ton voilà choisissons
cet objectif pour jour voilà me mets ton
qu'il ya ya pas mal de gens qui prennent
de la coke et et et des alcools et des
psychotropes mais il y en a d'une
manière générale en france énormément
bien sûr le monde est sous psychotropes
bien sûr on est en train de ne pas que
des gens il ya même des chats perchés
sortie de la projection les gens disent
est ce que tu peux nous donner le 06 de
son dealer qua
non mais c'est à dire que c'est très
très petit coup c'est un film très
stylisé très dirais que c'est presque un
film un hyperréalisme
fantasmagorique eu et moi j'ai voulu
faire un film qui ressemble au metteur
en scène que j'admire et donc je me suis
inspiré visuellement stylistiquement pas
de jambes énergie sont bunuel tarkovski
dario argento le père jean tolbert
d'asia bien sûr kubrick m'apprenez verbe
déjà à vos j 2 au delà qui vont aller au
delà
[Applaudissements]
c'est une oeuvre d'art mais ce qu'on
sait pas sera ariel c'est qu'elle elle
aime travailler l'image et c'est une
très bonne technicienne de deux grosses
prod sa soirée elle expérimente beaucoup
de choses et commence à avoir beaucoup
de maîtrise non mais je ne dis pas non
quand je dois être humain oui mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup j'ai
toujours aimé mélanger les supports même
la 3d j'aime les effets spéciaux je met
longtemps à les fabriquer parce que tout
ça est fait de manière artisanale et
sans argent et je crois que le méliès
temps mais à côté
ce serait
[Musique]
des choses
or vous déclare je suis touché par les
gilet jaune
j'adore leur phrase moi la fin du monde
je m'en fous je pense à la fin du mois
alors ça ça vous a plu cette phrase mais
c'est à dire que je crois qu'on est dans
une époque où pour la première fois
l'humanité enfin je suis pas sûr que ce
soit la première fois on se rend compte
que la fin du monde est possible et
qu'elle est là ça peut arriver et donc
les sociétés sont dans une espèce
d'inquiétude et en france
alors que c'est un pays on est quand
même extraordinairement gâté il ya ce
grand mouvement quand même d'inquiétude
de gens qui ne se sentent pas bien et
qui en même temps vous brisent le coeur
parce que quand on entend singulièrement
les revendications des gilet jaune et
bien c'est toujours sonne ne peut être
insensible personne ne peut être
insensible et c'est ça la force de du
moment qu'il ya 60% des français qu'il
est qui les soutient alors est-ce que
marrakech pendant les fêtes de noël il
n'y avait pas de gilet jaune ont mérité
mais moi j'avais un bikini jaune
et leur plus beau soutien ça
parce que là on a vu vous veut magnéto
serge
haouzi
one au coaching un texto for speed
olalala c'est magnifique
wayne et rick est
innovant toyota y en a là c'est
magnifique
une amie un pin mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà aliens crystal palace quand on
dit que l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
à 20 ans à l'interview d'avenir
l'interview trop sympa
[Musique]
alors venir est-ce que vous donnez vos
vieux vêtements et des associations oui
oui surtout à ma famille en fait
d'accord
est-ce que vous prêtez facilement de
l'argent à vos potes ouais à quel
intérêt par don
mello
est-ce que vous prêtez votre voiture
votre beau frère j'ai pas de voiture pas
de beau frère si j'ai un beau frère joe
pilote est ce que vous gardez les
enfants de vos proches pour leur faire
plaisir j'ai pas de patience à la pas de
voiture pas de patience parce que vous
aider les jeunes quinquas qu'elle craque
cap ne crevé par exemple est-ce que vous
avez les des jeux oui j'ai déjà tenté
mais ça ne m'est pas de grignan parce
que je
[Musique]
sais qu'il a rien et que sa gueule c'est
pas super mission est-ce que vous aider
les aveugles à traverser la rue oui pas
d'aveux aidé
et je te jure que c'est bizarre mais un
mais quand je vois une personne âgée
même s'il veut pas traverser la rue
est-ce que vous aidez les vieilles dames
à ramasser les crottes de leurs chiens
non non et des crottes à toi est ce que
vous ne m'aurez pas d'ailleurs
j'étais embarqué dans un peu les gars
mais
est ce que vous demandez un doggy bag au
resto pour donner à des sdf non mais je
mets je pourrais demander un doggy bag
pour prendre ce que j'ai pas terminé de
manger lorsque je hais le gaspillage
alimentaire ça c'est un garçon
exemplaire tu sais tu vois comme tu es
loin de lui françois toi qui es une
merde
est ce que si un crush vous le demandez
vous feriez comme richard berry vous le
donne rien rien évidemment la santé
avant tout la famille avant tout il en
resterait 1 alors que méline mais ville
dit amir combien tu as draps 3 c'est pas
vrai étant à la fédé mais ils sont
fonctionnels des 3 way un convoi combien
de fois par jour tu puisses
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous avez toujours une bonne
blague a raconté pour détendre
l'atmosphère
tu as vu comme je parle lentement oui
j'ai le temps que je termine la blague
ils vont perdre
l'habitude connaît une blague je connais
une blague j'en connais plein les yeux
ok on va essayer rêver de secondes ça va
venir
on est mardi déjà
ok c'est un mec qui rentre dans un bas
et qui dit au barman je voudrais inverse
pour moi un verre pour toi est inverse
pour tout le bas bon le gars il est
content il fait la tournée tout le monde
à la fin il lui dit de règle étant dit
j'ai pas d'argent ni quoi t'as pas
d'allant j'ai pas d'argent il commença à
lui rentrer dedans violemment le mec
s'en est pris plein la gueule n'a
évidemment pas payer les partis la
semaine d'après il revient il dit la
même chose je vais inverse pour -
inverse pour toi est inverse pour tous
les clients dans le bas alors tu as le
le barman qui quasiment il a il appris
sa leçon mon avis maintenant il s'est
redressé il fait la même chose il sert à
la fin il dit l'addition sept ans il
désolé j'ai un mec là il n'en peut plus
il erra jeudi lui explose de crâne ne
mais qui va un mois à l'hôpital un mois
de convalescence il retourne encore une
fois au bar en chaise roulante il dit
maintenant je veux un verre pour moi et
envers pour tous les clients dans le
barman et 10 mai mais moins tu m'invites
plus cette fois ci il en toi quand tu
bois tu deviens violent
eh ben ça va ça va
dit il
jusqu'ici ce soir pierre arditi pour que
je vous pose des questions lamentable et
je crois que vous n'avez pas être
d'issue par exemple ça a été des
escaliers la ans a tenu bon c'est pas la
honte qui pose problème c'est les genoux
c'est très sympa avec beats et à quoi
vous verrez ça va vous inquiétez pas ça
va vous arriver alors il avait déclaré
le chien grand père complètement gâteux
pourquoi préciser grand père
et nous entendons donc et donc qu'il y
aurait il répond ça donne alors n'y a
pas de réponse c'est lamentable du cto
1,6 que johan mois et la vérité sur fin
de carrière avant de trouver j'ai trouvé
une photo de vous au réveil oui regardez
lamentable
alors au point où on en est je crois que
plus simple décret de le sujet c'est de
regarder tous les amants table un
best-of de lamentables faisons pas venu
pour
manier tous tellement lamentable c'est
lamentable lamentable
une fois de plus c'est lamentable
l'amour n'a fait nulle la montagne c'est
lamentable honnêtement ça c'est vraiment
lamentable cette émission c'est vraiment
lamentable
vous fait plaisir
alors qu'un doute ici ce soir une pièce
de théâtre
fera décoller dont vous partagez
l'affiché que michel leeb oui oui le
problème l'inventaire quelqu'un quand
vous avez rencontré michel leeb oui
est-ce que j'ai été étonné qu'il n'ait
pas l'accent africain alors chasse c'est
intéressant commerciaux et
la pièce s'appelle compromis gerrans de
vos noms comme alibi en scène sylvia jeu
philippe caudal with en scène par le
grand bernard murat le pitch pierre
arditi est obligé de faire un compromis
et il partage l'affiché avec un gars qui
fait la mouche
exactement alors davantage de faire la
mouche c'est que les mouches vous ont
jamais accuser d'être raciste jamais ça
c'est l'avantagé très amis des mouches
des mouchards aide même
regard ce regard se battent chilhac
bonheur j'aime beaucoup et alors il a
cette petite nouvelle coupe de cheveux
un peu grisonnante comme ça tu as bien
fait une extension des péniches et droit
enfin ça c'est pathétique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce qu'on va faire on a commencé
pierre une nouvelle série si vous voulez
bien oui de pathétique mais dans les dix
ans qui viennent on va oublier
lamentable oui et on va faire petit hic
d'accord à marche c'est le duo duel de
la rentrée duo duel c'est la première
fois que vous jouez ensemble oui et
pierre arditi et michel leeb c'est un
sacré compromis il
ya neck vétérans mais on peut le dire
c'est bizarre quand même d'avoir réuni
le gars de pub du crédit lyonnais et le
gars de la pub bégon jaune magnéto serge
vous m'éclairer
je dessine
alors comment ne pas l'être on ne combat
pas les insectes qui font comme les
insectes qui font
alors contrôler la pgo jaune et
contrôlée
ça allait bien mais
ça commence
ces passionnés du spa ti ti jupette qui
collait plus souvent lamentables c'est
quand même très intéressant dans cet
enfer et l'unis on est ravi de mon
devoir y en a qui fait parfaitement
l'africain et l'autre qui est parfait
dans le rôle du mec consterné par les
vannes de thierry ardisson est d'accord
alors ça sent les missions lamentable à
la
saccharine utah maxime dire alors bien
vous l'aimiez michel leeb ou c'est
quelqu'un que tu vas pas de souchez
michèle nesme demandé en effet pierre
arditi bon mais on va y venir d'accord
j'aime bien michel desbois je l'aimé
bien que vous aider à vendre j'ai des
biens avant je le trouvais sympathique
je trouvais qu'il avait du talent là
elles mécanicien pas en fait et depuis
on se connaissait pas énorme et voilà
son passé cette rencontre est la main on
s'est rencontré et si je dois dire que
c'est une rencontre très agréable et
très fraternelle michel leeb vous
trouvez pas qu'il cabotine un peu comme
moi ce que moi j'ai toujours aimé ça
quand je les ai vus j'ai été bon c'est
mes grands parents qui m'ont demandé
d'aller le voir tout petit et jouets à
alençon un remake de nicolas et
pimprenelle il était remarquable tu as
oublié sarah bernhardt mais si tu peux
sortir sera pas mais j'aimerais beaucoup
de sortir sa remarque que j'avais de
l'admiration pour lui le roi ils sont
pires que nous là c'est plutôt et le
marché au fond du théâtre
le fait que michel leeb et tourné dans
goldfinger ça vous que j'aime pas et est
un porno ce we got
more aime pas le mot voilà voilà le chat
même pas le mou
j'ai tourné ça effectivement pour payer
mes études voilà et puis c'est pas grave
évidemment et surtout je restais un bon
aussi mais à ce couple s'appelle alice
et chloé un truc comme ça c'est ce qu'on
dit maintenant je rêvais celui-là
c'était tourné par sina ce qui était
très connu qui s'appelait renégats ville
ah oui tiens magenta est illuminée comme
ça c'était un vrai porno
un film érotique c'est l'avenir au
dessus sur la fiche qui à la photo la
plus grande un local affiche la fils du
théâtre
moi aussi bon lui je regarde soit que
celle de l'ebe est un peu plus grand
nombre non je m'en fous complètement moi
aussi alors c'est qui le plus payé le
plus payé alors ça moi je sais que je
suis payé comme lui
achèterais bien oui ça leur crée lequel
connaît le mieux son texte alors c'est
moins de nous deux non c'est moi non
alors sérieusement je vais vous
expliquer dampierre travail quand même
si la politique ne nous reste plus que
dix permettent oui mais voilà comment ça
se passe quand pierre est en scène n'ont
donc quand il a soit disant travailler
depuis six semaines le texte alors je
vais te dire une joue alors alors alors
alors est alors écoute mon écoute moi
bien alors à l'orge est alors alors la
jouer alors je vais te dire pendant ce
temps là il cherche le mot qui va le
suivre alors alors je vais te dire je
vais te dire que ce n'est pas bien donc
il met 25 minutes sortir c'est beaucoup
plus long évidemment
tout le monde se disent est extrêmement
drôle mais en fait ils rament et donc je
vais donc vous expliquer le mode de
fonctionnement de mon ami michel cymes
et dans le système absolument inverse
sais pas car il a les mêmes trous de
mémoire que les miens il simplement ça
ne se décrit pas de la même manière
c'est à dire que lui il a mémorisé les
blancs magnétique en train mots et un
autre mot qui n'arrivent pas à trouver
car il fait alors je voudrais
vous dire
que
si tu le veux pas
et donc si tu ve république ne sais pas
ce que c'est que de lomagne était en
réalité de la vraie durée de la pièce la
vraie durée de la pièce ses 24 minutes
mais entre nous deux ceintures à 12h45 à
nadal je vous adore je me réjouis d'y
aller de ses 110 qui suit voir toutes
les pièces tu le sais bien bon alors je
suis de la merde
sans réelle abc
comme ses ficelles
un jackie chan robien rohner rover
[Musique]
rover alors le pic ses deux amis de 30
ans qui sont dans un appartement qui
nous plaît bien ici vous êtes un
comédien médiocre absolument se
souvenant revenons à la pièce
vous êtes un dramaturge raté voilà alors
pierre vend son appartement et il a
demandé à michel d'être présent pour la
signature du compromis avec l'acheteur
donc en attendant d'acheteurs il
commence à discuter puis comme souvent
dans ce genre de situation ils finissent
par se dire leurs quatre vérités iris
par s'engueuler
jeu del
pitoyable
ça c'est quand on aura 80 ans je te
propose que tous nos soixante dix ans
les fesses sur pathétique et quand on
aura 80 on passe à l'autre objectif ça
marche alors évidemment il ya un
compromis avec l'acheteur mais aussi des
compromissions c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est à dire que produit si
vous demandez à un michel de pas dire
qu'il ya de l'amiante dans les murs et
que des tuyaux sont pleins donc ça soude
la combine si on le vit d'amour alors le
seul problème j'ai dénoncé comme samedi
par exemple le postillon vous avez fait
un peu ce sillon samedi est douce mais
comment ce que c'est vrai ou cette
adresse bah oui oui oui alors on
n'arrache pas dans son pub au studio
n'est pas ça c'est le cas cela on
déclenche et là on est dans la
quintessence oui de sequins ringard peut
faire pour attirer l'attention sur lui
alors c'est à dire que j'ai dû avoir un
petit à petit dans des petits matches
comme ça non l'autre a fait comme si je
lui avec la biodanza non non non les
ventes et en phrases comme ça pile en
face les gens dehors du légume destiné
aux michel j'avais pris dans leur merde
comme comme rodrigue comme rodrigue
landry dans l'oeil je me sens comme dit
jean marie bigard c'était un mal alors
ce que dit pas place les gens dans la
salle ont adoré parce qu'après vous
n'arrivez plus à jouer le fait mort de
rire les grands moments théâtraux grands
moments où ça faudra pas trop le répéter
30 ans s'en va se faire cogner
violemment toujours est il que vous êtes
devenus les meilleurs amis du monde et
que maintenant vous êtes ensemble tout
le temps et là par exemple sur la photo
vous essayez de faire 1 1 sél fille
alors ce qu'il faut
c'est dans l'autre sens c'est dieu qui
seul le chef
c'est dans l'autre sens
bon finisseur si la saison des
récompenses on va voir si vous êtes prêt
à ne pas en avoir on va faire une
interview pas de césar
bible à chaud vous êtes ici ce soir
parce que vous venez de ne pas recevoir
de césar du meilleur film pour nicky
larson
c'est déjà le quatrième césar que vous
ne recevez pas est-ce que c'est toujours
la même émotion
absolument je vois on travaille dur pour
justement rater cette récompense et
c'est pas si simple comment est-ce que
c'est déjà un honneur ne pas être nommé
absolument thierry
on finit par s'habituer quand même vous
serez déjà en marche et j'étais de
l'année dernière et césar du public
voilà et j'étais le troisième film qui
avait fait le plus d'entrées donc j'ai
quand même vu mon film à la cérémonie
voilà peut-être celui-ci
est ce que vous avez une pensée pour
tous ceux qui ont eu un césar et qui
sont dégoûtés à l'heure qu'il est
oui enfin c'est des petites pensées
parce que je pense que ils sont pas de
trop trop trop dégoûté non non c'est pas
ça fait plaisir de recevoir cette soirée
plaisir
évidemment enfin je t'encourage à mais
oui je sais je sais je sais très bien
maintenant les films qui marchent et qui
font rire les entendra enfin tous ceux
qui font de la comédie étudiants pour
nous le plus important est évidemment de
faire public le public tendance alors
j'imagine que ça fait longtemps que vous
rêvez de ne pas avoir de césar ça fait
30 ans que qu'est ce que tu veux
répondre
oui ça fait longtemps que je parle des
césars parce que après on risquerait de
me proposer d'autres genres de films et
moi je veux faire des comédies voilà
c'est bien parti pour ça j'ai lu dans le
magazine le point que philippe était
considéré comme nous francis le blé
mais alors ça si c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai c'est un truc de ouf mais c'est un
truc tout ce que moi celui qui m'a donné
envie de faire ce métier c'est francis
veber avec pierre richard bah voila je
voyais mes parents rire devant ses films
dans le canapé donc je connais les films
par coeur et je vais même remercier du
coup au générique de baby sitting j'ai
dit merci francis veber et pierre
richard pour m'avoir envie de faire ce
métier voilà
est ce que vous espérez qu'un jour on
vous aime pas un césar pour l'ensemble
de votre oeuvre mais le graal ce serait
de ne pas avoir de ce carcan oui oui
c'est ça c'est ça j'espère surtout ne
jamais avoir d'oscar pas du tout non
mais surtout pas après obligé de tourner
avec brad pitt dicaprio tous les gens
dont je suis fan
comment savez-vous by malama chavez
bonsoir miss france 2010 9 je crois
qu'il ya depuis longtemps pas une aussi
jolie sera entièrement d'accord tiens
on a bien fait d'ouvrir le concours
entend sexuelle
s'est présenté tout le monde d'ailleurs
juste l'accent qui fait déborder
qui en fait vous ne connaissez pas
laurent baffie pas encore mais bon je
tâte le terrain là et après ça sera moi
alors je rappelle les principes du
concours miss france donc des jeunes
filles qui veulent devenir médecin
vétérinaire qui gagne et qui finissent
animatrice sur la tnt c'est ça c'est un
point de vue en ce qui me concerne je
souhaite terminer professeur de
marketing dans un lycée ou à janvier les
élèves
sinon
ça risque d'être pas facile
ça va lui plaire encore plus
attention vous allez finir le coin
où s'arrête pas là non seulement c'est
la plus belle
alors vas y j'imagine qu'en tant que
miss france vous êtes pour la paix dans
le monde également laurent fils qua non
non j'ai pas dit de lever nier la non à
la pâte en 17 minutes peut revenir
maîtresse s'il vous plaît non excusez
vous d'abord je m'excuse maîtresse je
tolère pour cette fois
et je n'ai pas prêté ces foutus 10 à
papeete tahiti
raté on dit pas c
est ce que tu sais ce que je dis le
prénom d'une avarie malama écoute j'ai
pas pour habitude de l'insulté comme
avant donc je ne traduirait pas ça veut
dire source de lumière assez joli enfin
c'était le deuxième prénom de lady di
ouais mais
chut
[Musique]
15 décembre 2018 à lille si j'avais été
élue miss france la 89e du nom magnéto
serge
miss france
2010 9 et miss tahiti
[Musique]
premier nommé
posez impression
oh
c'est
eh ben
ils s'incrustent y attend quand même
bien de mâcon plus personne dit
s'appeler style là bas ça veut dire
[ __ ] de bordel accueil
mesurer combien elle mètre soixante dix
huit cent des talents a laissé sa mère
parce que là quand vous avez la robe sur
scène c'est incroyable c'est magnifique
elle est très claire très très belle
silhouette alors tout le monde vous
adore même mélenchon
chavez a bien
bien foutu comme un vrai bien alors en
venant les joueurs à gagner plein de
trucs une suite de
245 mètres carrés au george de 5 ha bon
une nuit s'ils savaient pas combien le
musée et je me suis perdu le 5 mai que
j'ai fait cette nuit là on peut pas dire
si j'ai déjà je n'ai pas d'amis tu
m'étonnes parce que on a quitté en
aquitaine il devait être une heure du
matin le temps de lever ni le vert pâle
il était 3h 4h du matin mais j'ai été
prendre un bain à la place d'accord
parce que je trouvais que c'était charef
j'arrivais pas de lui qu'il avait avec
vous y avez sylvie il ya réalisé il y
avait
beaucoup de monde pour ce qu'on n'est
pas
on était au dos vous avez gagné dix
montres c'est difficile de porter de 10
monde quand même et je peux en poste et
qui
n'ont jamais gagné la wii alors ce qui
est complètement con vous avez gagné un
voyage à l'île maurice vous venez de
tahiti sur le rythme en compte
merial au versement
évidemment ça c'est pas jeunes habillés
qui est bien aussi je connais pas encore
mais je vais te faire découvrir jeu
[Musique]
c'est un moyen c'est pas grave c'est
pour faire voyager les gens à je sais
que c'est pas tahitien bon alors est ce
qu'en tant que tahitienne en revanche
vous premier douche dehors quand il
pleut ça allait me tuer mais pas en
france bon ben ça alors vos parents ont
fait 18 mille kilomètres pour venir
assister au couronnement votre père est
employé de poste à papeete oui votre
mère est infirmière oui bah papeete non
elle est à côté elle est après
deux jours de bateau
mythique c'est ça ça faisait au 73 km de
long ont fait le tour de l'île en deux
heures en voiture ah oui ça revient
navale alors une dimension de la
métropole vous aviez deux ans quand vos
parents seront séparés donc toutes vos
dit souhaiter en garde alternée ça et
alors alors ces filles ont fui ou c'est
un montage siens qui a été francisé je
vous laisserai à les regarder c'est
chiant
passif
qui me disait tu échoues à 18 ans comme
beaucoup d'adolescents en polynésie vous
étiez en surpoids il ya un enfant sur
trois en polynésie qui sauf le décès le
poids ou d'obésité effectivement c'est
incroyable c'est donc qu'elle vous
posiez ses
84 kg savoir j'arrive de tahiti c'est
vrai qu'au petit déjeuner ils sont tous
les enfants en train de boire du
des boissons sucrées du grave mais c'est
incroyable des bouffées mais
s'entraînant énormément de sucre tout le
temps partout pas
[Musique]
alors à l'époque
vous ne vous peignez plus les cheveux
vous portez des gros charlot de surf
vous avez des landes enfin c'est
effectivement vous laisse ébahis vous
laisser un peu aller à l'époque c'est
vraiment oui beaucoup
quand on vous voit là on n'arrive pas à
le croire et la métamorphose
donc on le disait buy in et c'est gonflé
et là et la mission sport
musique à l'école c'est incroyable quand
tu vois ses camarades d'appeler le
monstre le monstre ça donne de l'espoir
ah ouais et puis un jour où vous
regardez dans le miroir et là ça repart
vous dites je suis forte et je vais y
arriver et vous décidez que tout ce que
les gens pourront vous dire vous vous en
[ __ ] et ça ne toucherait pas je décide
que c'est moi qui compte est plus ce qu
ils disent ne passe pas avant ce que moi
je penses tu pas qu'on
sait les nuits se mettent à travers les
danses à la fosse et
pourtant elle sent tout c'est dommage
que vous ne le voyez comme maintenant
la guide laurent blanc a là il a raison
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai abandonné 9 h 10 - oui c'est
aux émois maîtresse voilà comment elle à
millau le bidon et moi est ce que je me
comporte bien maîtresse
l'invité
alors à partir de ce moment-là vous
changé votre façon de manger vous faites
du sport et vous décidez donc de vous
présenter au concours de miss c'est à la
suite de plusieurs événements
effectivement non non non
elle va gaulle est aussi éteint vous
inquiétez pas je le surveille aussi les
yeux partout
non mais quand vous décidez de présenter
les concours de miss votre maman on le
prend très mal ce que mon amant elle
n'est pas d'accord avec avec ce que j'ai
envie de faire elle a d'autres projets
pour le mois alors vous êtes ultra
déterminé parce que vous devenez miss
tahiti en obtenant un master en
management mine de rien quand même un
peu les cheveux
tu as vu comment elle te manager pour la
fin aulas
je savais plus qui voteront la première
fois quelqu'un mais bien à la demande
comme ça il obéit tu as vu le guen alors
cette détermination
aujourd'hui vous la tournée contre le
harcèlement scolaire
il peut revenir lassés du harcèlement
scolaire laurent c'est un sujet que tu
connais ça oui bon c'est nier beaucoup
j'étais harcelée par mes profs qui
voulaient train que j'apprenne mais le
son c'est qu'on
imagine les legs que c'était là ça
n'allait pas être facile non pas du tout
sept cent mille gosses sont victimes de
harcèlement scolaire mine de rien c'est
beaucoup non bien sûr alors qu'est ce
que vous faites pour ça parce que eh
bien pour l'instant je ne sais pas
encore ce qu'est ce qu'il faut faire je
souhaite écouter d'abord parce que c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus important en réalité
on a trop tendance à parler pour ne rien
dire en fait parce qu'on a envie d'avoir
de la parole est ce qui compte c'est de
savoir comment est ce qu'il faudrait
réagir les poules ça il faut une réalité
du terrain donc posé des questions
pertinentes écouter les réponses et voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut agir par
rapport à ça
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui de faire de votre 42 avec
mercier alors sylvie tellier a dit les
français ont voté pour les rondeurs
cette année et je trouve ça chouette est
sympa sylvie tellier nord franchement
elle est géniale bon j'aime bien sympa
si oui atelier nous
sympa
non ce tu peux me laisser dormir oui
c'est bien sûr génial alors il ya un
truc terrible quel est il ce qui paraît
que jeudi soir pour la saint valentin
vous étiez seul enfin oui non je termine
des copines ah bon d'accord oui et on a
fait une soirée une saint valentin à
cesson bien que c'est à dire ben la clac
et copines raclée des lobbies d'accord
c'est bon ça fait contrepèterie raclette
et copines fait n'ont pas envie de
mélanger pas dire qu'on l'a à voir
avec de la raquette probablement
même si quelque chose arrive bail elle
adore les blagues nulles un jeu de tir
avec ballons 20 si tu la trouves comment
appelle-t-on une manifestation d'
aveugle festival de cannes
initialement faire une interview à quel
âge
même la vie
mais on what
[Applaudissements]
alors vous me dites à quel âge pourrait
correspondre ses phrases pour vous j'ai
voulu faire etc trice
six ans ouais ouais ouais j'étais quand
même vraiment bien gaulée à quel âge
jusqu'à jusqu'à on va dire
la quarantaine j'avais vraiment pas une
thune
alors j'ai eu de la chance ça m'est
jamais arrivé comme j'étais petit
c'était dur à la maison quand même parce
que quand même ça ramait à côté des
huissiers qui vient la maison est mais
moi j'ai jamais manqué de rien parce que
mon père supportait pas l'idée que je
n'ai rien ce meuble ses amis voilà et
quand c'est parce qu'on faisait à
l'époque des
des saisies dans l'appartement et donc
il fait venir les copains et quand le
lui se disait bon bah voilà là et c'est
en ce fauteuil cette table etc donc il y
avait le copain de mon père qui a
racheté l'immeuble donc lui-même ne
partait pas de la maison c'était génial
aussi c'est de ton père aller dans des
boutiques de jouets se couvrait de
cadeaux en faisant des chèques sans
provision de temps oui et donc ont mené
le dimanche d'après il monsieur disait à
mon père excusez moi mais là le chèque
n'était pas approvisionnée à bon gros
comme ça bon je vous en fais un autre
j'ai eu un sens commun
joe culture mon mec à quel âge
le premier a tous d'accord
sexuellement c'était le top à quel âge
oh je pense qu a pas d'âge il ya les
partenaires j'étais dépressive à quel
âge
42 43 comme j'ai divorcé
ça va vous aime bien mais ben oui bah
bien sûr mais il faut se soigner
et ça a fait un bon spectacle coécrit
par marie-pascale osterrieth ma vie
[Applaudissements]
la fin de ma carrière que parent je
serai chez l'ancien jour ça va bien
qu'un jour alors j'ai arrêté de croire
la fidélité à 15 h
d'ailleurs
j'ai fait le deuil de mes parents
n'en voulait pas faire n'importe quel
âge je vais te tuer je pense qu'il a pas
d'âge pour être orphelin ouais et moi je
le sens en mes parents tous les jours de
même j'ai fait la paix avec les macaques
et nage je sors pas ah ouais oman ont vu
les sig marque j'ai croisé là
je fais pas la pression
j'ai fait la paix avec moi même à quel
âge
je vais pas tarder
[Rires]
ici ce soir pour annoncer au monde
entier qu'elle est enceinte
votre nouveau spectacle au casino de
paris donc du 12 au 19 janvier puis une
tournée dans toute la france évidemment
qu'en juin 2010 9,7 à lens voilà fort
mauvais non plus ah oui y'a pas de bande
annonce la bande annonce comme disait
petites ficelles et l bah oui c'est un
spectacle vivant et s'appuient sur ça va
pas durer l underground higuain
[Musique]
dans la plaie en d'euros de gains
peut-être à cause de can eat peut-être à
cause de ça
au nord
pourquoi
appeler de plus de deux morts parce que
je commence une carrière internationale
donc en dehors de gueule est avec les
gens ne comprennent pas beaucoup ce que
ça donne rien c'est vrai votre mari
l'appelle pas le spectacle on the road
again ils appellent enfin peinard tout
seul à la maison on affiche la finale à
l'affiché sublime pas d'affichés
vachement bien vous avez un côté là
alors là c'est marrant je peux vous
raconter savez si je sais qu'à la fin de
la séance je déteste ça des photos et la
fin de la soeur j'étais fatigué j'ai mis
mes cheveux en avant et hop le
photographe de génie du photographe
pascal tôt a surpris le regard ni
d'ingénieurs n'est pas qu'ils se moquent
un peu de vous
pourquoi vous théâtre va bien si j'adore
ça vous modernise amour qu'en fait non
oui je pensais qu'aujourd'hui je suis
arrivé comme ça moi peut-être gens
étaient fermées alors comme il n'y a pas
de bande annonce on va vous demander de
quoi vous avez parlé est-ce que vous
avez parlé de michel oui un petit peu
allez bon on n'est pas mal non seulement
ils sont deux
alors il paraît que michel j'avais peur
de toucher des fois avec vous ce que
vous faites attention but commun c'est
quelquefois il ya peu vexé mais ceci dit
irrite tous les soirs
je parle de lui c'est comme paludisme et
sétois dont elle se moque du produit
tout c'est pas moi oui les neuneus où il
une mauvaise foi totale
est ce que j'avais parlé de vos petits
enfants parce que yahvé georges baby
george v déjà eu 91 à gabriel gabriel et
deux petits enfants et mon petit fils
est adorable petit fils m'appelle momie
babines film
et l'autre jour et de berry et allemands
et avec son mari y avait un grain de
grandes plaines de serre comme ça avec
benoît gigantesque du oui/non céda et
mon petit fils a fait momie comme ça
il sait que c'est quoi que c'est bon
sérieusement il paraît que les petits
enfants quand ils prêts c'est vrai en
plus quand il passe du temps avec
chantal quand ils reviennent c'est sa
fille il arrive plus articulés
[Applaudissements]
comme habile à michel bien les petits
enfants il ya giovanni diasio en manie
regarder du roi callaway
hall à la voile alors j'ai présenté les
vous a tellement troublés aux nrj music
awards que vous avez annoncé le gagnant
de la chanson internationale de l'année
avant la fin du magnéto de présentation
la boulette la boulette non je comprends
rien ses émissions ça crie trop fort ça
parle pas la musique et les gens crient
et sur ce thème je ne convenais du
revenu quand même mais pas mal je vais
animer les frais sympa et il est pas con
pour un beau garçon
c'est vrai souvent dit les dents rien
c'est alors que vous deux est moche mais
ils sont intelligents je vais trouver
des lois m pour
alors donc on la lui michel les
petits-enfants giovanni est ce que vous
avez parlé de ça c'est un truc de la
tentative de viol la sur le bateau là
anne on vous en parlait pas c'est vrai
vous avez entendu ça quelque part c'est
vrai j'ai visité un bateau mais qui dit
bien dans mon bateau et viva et quant à
la visite le bateau le mec la bouche
dans une cabine et il a essayé s'est
bâtie par trois même si
j'ai pas réussi à le virer
[Applaudissements]
or jeunes ont proposé des photos que je
n'ai jamais su bien d'enquêté ce gars là
je vous posais des photos de suspects et
vous allez dire si vous les reconnaissez
voilà c'est liu jo all suspecte on
commence est-ce que c'est lui est-ce que
c'est lui est-ce que c'est lui
ferron et ça me détruit enrôler est-ce
que c'est lui
alors c'est lui je suis sûr que c'est le
suivre lui
et j'ai rencontré non parce que sinon
mais une autre solution c'est lui qui
s'est battu stuff comme christophe
colomb
l'important c'est qu'il ne soit pas
arrivé à ses fins exact ce [ __ ] et
j'étais hier un plat lcd quand ça
va très longtemps a été daté au carbone
oh
sous la
main
il ya un truc je sais pas s'il va en
parler c'est la période sombre de votre
vie oui quand vous étiez prostituées
magnéto serge
jean mignon il fut
le père avait eu
oui mais je cherche monsieur charles
vernois tu connaîtras connaît pas
qu'est ce que tu lui veut à charles
vernois
[Musique]
volée alors allez bien la [ __ ] f les
députés des concerts et j'en ai marre
j'ai arrêté déjà fait de l'asean ouais
avec quel succès mais j'ai failli
d'ailleurs j'ai failli ça les valseuses
quand même hein ah oui j'ai fait le
casting des valseuses à la passe de deux
bars du nom alors le mieux oui au figaro
marc lemay qu'un mode et me dit enlève
son soutien gorge est antichoc et j'ai
pas j'ai pas voulu le faire non j'ai
fait des photos et quelques corps mais
maintenant vous ne sauriez voulons
maintenant je le sais ils sont punis
mais je le fais mais si vous voulez j'ai
pas voulu faire donc j'ai pas eu le rôle
j'ai raconté ça depardieu il ya pas
longtemps vanité câblée montrer
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
hu
alors lambert wilson malgré votre
immense carrière vous êtes toujours
aussi humble il est temps que ça change
on va faire une interview alain delon
derrière
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que lambert
wilson peut tout jouer
lambert wilson ne pose il peut toujours
y relevé
pourquoi pensez vous que les femmes
aiment autant lambert wilson les femmes
aiment lambert wilson pense que l'on
verra une jeune et beau
pourquoi pensez vous que les jeunes en
attendant ben wilson et les hommes
aiment beaucoup lambert wilson parce que
les hommes aiment leur femme qui est
blanc ben oui ou
non nous sommes pas hostiles que ces
films sera un jour étudier dans les dix
et lambert wilson c'est que ces films
sont étudiées dans les lycées car la
princesse de montpensier étaient unis
dans les lycées lambert wilson
trouve-t-il qu'un théâtre lambert wilson
serait quand même la moindre des choses
non mais oui ça ne pose qu'un opéra
serait mieux dessiner c'est rock garnier
on sait même plus qui sait alors que
lambert wilson et oui est-ce que vous
pensez que lambert wilson doit beaucoup
à son extraordinaire physique et lambert
wilson doit beaucoup à son nez ah oui et
en général quand on a un grand mère
les gros ne me reste que lambert wilson
compte bientôt avoir une rue à son nom
lambert wilson a déjà une avenue
attendons la venue du président
est ce que l'on met le savent est une
star au japon
lambert wilson ignore le japon
seuls robert wilson est ce que lambert
wilson pense que je mérite vraiment de
le recevoir ce soir
jeunes apprécient cette invitation
comment lambert wilson conclure est-il
cette interview pour laisser une trace
indélébile dans l'histoire de la
télévision française
je vous ai compris
qu inspire
[Musique]
le bundle
[Applaudissements]
donc d'abord laurent si tu vois ta
soirée hier bien sûr dont papa papa pas
encore au pic est pas encore ma soir il
y avait un proton sciages eymétois
n'importe où mais n'est pas comme moi
parce qu'il souffle à oued souf par
ailleurs tu m'as demandé de m'asseoir
ailleurs alors c'est comme jacques
allait très bien attention
ce soir le thème du green tech séné
surnom c'est en hommage à désavouer m la
tortue donc les surnoms voilà d'ailleurs
vous devez trouver un qui chantent mais
si vous trouvez le surnom là vous
marquez deux points évidemment alors là
le vainqueur devra célébrer sa victoire
comme un joueur de foot qui marque un
but on a regardé d'ailleurs les
meilleurs célébration
saison
magnéto serge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
mais voilà
attention musique
qui chantent iggy pop et hip hop
[Musique]
il y aura aussi j'ai chèque lui vaut un
an à radio
quel est son surnom guanghua ni les jeux
deviennent
2.2.9
[Applaudissements]
damballa moquer des iguanes c'est pas ça
c'est quand tu d'iggy pop tu as le droit
c'est à toi que revient le droit pour
défendre cette règle maintenant
deux fois
[Applaudissements]
je vois pas là où je suis encore plus
perché qu'ariel
[Rires]
attention musique
[Musique]
oh
oh la la
m
ça
entre elles
faudel deux modèles le surnom les petits
[Applaudissements]
travers attention musique
via via.b
les allées venues milan mais le chemin
lamiraux damon la môme bia noyau il
annonce alors que toi pour willem deux
points pour ariel a provoqué
mais l'or aux asseoir à ma table il fait
si peur de
me conforte à aller me lève il offre à
la la la la la la la la la
alors voilà la la la
[Applaudissements]
non ça fait trois points pourra rien
t'arriver
moi je t'aime je pense à toi c'est pas
mon
[Applaudissements]
attention là ça va très vite pour la
jcct
la caisse des
kings qui
y
sont toujours
je suis désolé vraiment je suis désolé
de ne pas tricher en fait
attention
on revient robien elles reviendront
jamais cela et bien non laurent
elle est finie c'est plus vite et
[Applaudissements]
je vous cracher dessus ce rigolo
attention musique
[Musique]
dutronc
c
donc avec ce genre d'armes fois beaucoup
plus qu'à trouver presque un point pour
ariane qui a trouvé le king
mais là les règles du jeu changent avec
arrière oui donc le jeu s'appelle ali
foccart et elle gagne voilà non pas du
tout pas du tout envie car ils gagnent
simplement tu n'y vois rien d'autre à
faire une célébration de foot je
préférerais que ce soit toi non parce
qu'elle pourrait sauver son maillot
après claudia serait chouette musique
open lors son parti comme sur
le deck de poids
on n'est pas obligé d'écouter ça non
plus hein c'est un jeu les surnoms de
boba c'est le petit ourson réussi 23 cm
qui gagne
match boublil et en tête est-ce que tu
acceptes tu es pas obligé d'accepter tu
peux partir avec ton gros pognon un mois
leur entrée le channel j'aime un système
de changes est-ce que tu acceptes le
super banco
en vrai je partirai avec ça mais je sens
que je vais décevoir tout le monde a
essayé superbe en cours
le super banco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
al hadj abdallah s'asservir originals
down to love tam mais bon c'est pour moi
à donzy musique
j'ai reconnu
brassens nougaro
qui dans l'autre sens carla bruni
mouloud fou et
ariane
moral arielle dombasle et son surnom la
chatte perché
la dame avait à chelles voilà d'un vab
et achète une chemise aussi bon donc
c'est de toute évidence max c'est lui
qui va nous faire effectivement la
célébration du match de foot attention
je les regarde ce qu'on aurait pu faire
christophe
mister mojo seulement moi
juste un génie que attention
[Applaudissements]
pas tant ses héros riels
ariel
je vous demande urgente et haley n'a pas
fait remarquer n'a rien de sûr attention
musique
[Applaudissements]
bien
non
[Applaudissements]
et
maintenant c'est l'heure des impôts 2
vise haut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu auras très bien vous dire ding
attention jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est parti et en corse par ce
constat le nombre de naissances continue
de baisser en france et donc
contrairement à emmanuel macron les
français eux savent se retirer au bon
moment
ouais c'est bien a conclu cette semaine
aurait déclaré je marche sur la glace et
nous on pensait avoir et luc et délits
et bim on se retrouve avec candeloro
[Applaudissements]
élections européennes à droite d'abord
wauquiez choisi un trio emmené par
françois-xavier bel habit qu'il est venu
d'ailleurs chez vous il ya quelques
semaines pour la liste lr
françois-xavier belle amie agnès séverin
et arnaud danjean sont les trois ça
faisait longtemps que chez les
républicains on n'avait plus vu de
nouveaux visages enfin je veux dire à
part celui de rachida dati
[Applaudissements]
diop
intentions elle a dit cette semaine elle
a dit rachid a poussé un coup de gueule
elle a dit après les critiques sur son
physique elle en a marre alors on va
mettre les choses au point à rachida
dati moi c'est pas tant physique que je
critique c'est son chirurgien
côté à gauche maintenant avec place
tudyk raphaël glucksmann se donne deux
mois pour unir la gauche
waouh dia drôle ouais la nuit je
commencerai par un objectif plus
accessible c'est pas à régler le conflit
israélo palestinien un truc un peu et
puis comme un malheur n'arrive jamais
seul bible lendemain ali dargaud soutien
place publique je pense vraiment que y'a
pas pire soutient faille avec ségolène
royal et et nordahl le landais mais
vatican le pape dit non au mariage des
prêtres tout de suite le cardinal
barbarin a tweeté et pour l'adoption
comment on fait
[Applaudissements]
les émirats arabes unis un bris pour
l'égalité femmes hommes a été décerné
mais seulement à des hommes bien oui bon
on ne va pas leur jeter la pierre bat
d'abord parce que c'est pas toujours mis
en france et puis surtout parce que là
bas c'est pas aux hommes qu on la jette
la pierre
politique internationale le forum
économique de davos s'est ouverte sans
trump sans macron sens theresa may ni
les etats-unis ni la france ni la grande
bretagne pour vous donner une idée c'est
comme si le forum international de la
pédophilie s'ouvrait ce sens la
thaïlande la belgique et le vatican
justice à faire des lasagnes de cheval
le procès spanghero a commencé cette
semaine en gros il s'agit d'une affaire
de faux et d'usagé de chevaux
mais difficilement oui petit jeu debout
sur le suaire est encore meilleur
toulouse une soeurs dominicaines accusé
d'agression sexuelle saluer de la soeurs
dominicaines strauss kahn
j'avais dit que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est un pas encore savoir laurent
les poêles anti-adhésives peuvent
réduire la taille du pénis de l'avs ai
dit voilà
c'est la conclusion d'une étude hyper
sérieux
par ailleurs ils ont analysé les
composantes chimiques dans les poêles à
20 alors moi je savais bien qu'ils
avaient quand même un argument
scientifique pour laisser les femmes
faire la cuisine sinon on dirait
attention dans le sens inverse il ya eu
une autre étude toujours sur la santé ce
maître du persil dans le vagin est une
pratique dangereuse voilà oui mais avoue
que c'est joli
il est franchement avec qui fait ça fait
apparaît briques caron qui paie sage
débouchèrent oil des nuits je sais pas
déjà et quand quand tu dragues une femme
et qu'elle a un goût de persil entre les
dents c'est gênant mais de là à voir
toute la botte
[Musique]
et en même temps mais je ne vous dis moi
je suis belge donc si vous ajoutez un
peu de muscade et des oignons entrant
chinois demeure à peu poire est un des
seuls ça fait une excellente recette de
boulot vin blanc
[Applaudissements]
on va en algérie où miss algérie et noir
cette année et c'est une première et ça
a provoqué un déferlement de racisme sur
les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs je peux
vous dire que quand eric zemmour appris
qu'ils avaient des arabes noirs il a
fait un avc
cela dit moi je dis chapeau aux
algériens parce que pour une fois lors
d'une élection ils élisent quelqu'un de
vivant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout autre chose d effet johnny hallyday
dans la galette des rois c'était la
nouveauté cette année c'est sympa il
paraît qu'il ya aussi des fèves david et
laura mais ils ont pas mis dans la
galette ils ont mis un côté à côté ils
regardent de loin leur part du gâteau
[Applaudissements]
people enfin julien lepers sous le coup
de deux redressements fiscaux c'est oui
oui c'est oui de à la suite assez beau
julien et vous partez avec
l'encyclopédie en 27 volumes de l'art de
se protéger l'anus en milieu carcéral
c'est oui
[Applaudissements]
allez les brèves aux usa un coureur
cycliste de 90 ans contrôlé positif qui
est riche poule avantages des contrôles
avec un sportif de cet âge là c'est que
pour le prélèvement du rin après la
course on lui demande juste son slip
et les visuels et les visuels cela
en suisse vient réclamons sahili a
réclamé sa drogue aux objets perdus
après avoir oublié sa valise de thil et
contenait dans le tgv alors j'ai d'abord
il s'est fait arrêter le conte
évidemment à
bavay ça c'est le problème quand t'as
pas inventé la poudre mais que tu veux
quand même la consommer
[Applaudissements]
à new york il lui demande sa main elle
lui dit oui et la bague tombe dans un
trou alors c'est pas de chance parce que
normalement après avoir offert la bague
c'est lui qui vivre la culture
à l'est cette semaine je vous emmène au
musée de la nourriture des goûteurs
alors c'est un petit cadeau de noël en
suède le dise que sting foule museum
s'est ouvert à malmö alors comme c'est
bientôt noël peut-être ça donnera des
idées il ya 80 plat produits ours est
dégoûtante l'occasion évidemment de
préparer son réveillon chez belle-maman
laïque à l'entrée du musée on offre des
sacs à vomi aux visiteurs les bérets des
cinq avocats de la nourriture des gueux
on se croirait sur un vol air france
commençons comment sont peut-être vous
en connaissez certains le kazoo marzouk
c'est un fromage de sardaigne dans
lequel deux petits asticots grouille on
en trouve aussi en corse et ça aussi ça
m'a surpris parce que c'est rare d'avoir
quelque chose d'encore ce qui se
brouille
je n'ai pas de villa en corse mais voilà
alors la suivante c'est une recette
philippines ce qu'on appelle le bal août
c'est à dire c'est un embryon d'oiseaux
bouillie dans sa coque ce que véronique
courjault appelle un kinder surprise
tout cas mais j'éviterai de servir ce
foetus à la cantine de sens commun
autres plaques aura son petit succès le
cochon dinde grillée ses spécialités au
pérou voilà c'est ce que passe-partout
appelle un cochon dinde de noël
grillades toujours avec la tarentule
grille est donc là méfiez vous si vous
propose un plat de pâtes
mais ce que j'aime ici c'est la
tentative d'amadouer avec des concombre
coupé en fleurs à côté pour donner un
petit peu revit plus étrange encore un
pénis de tout rond ça c'est le plat
préféré des féministes radicales
spécialités chinoises oui alors on
comprend aisément pourquoi le plat
exerce une forme de fascination en chine
ce qui serait moins le cas au sénégal
ouais ouais dans sa première vie
[Applaudissements]
alors là sur le boulot liane bloody mary
s'est sorti bloody mary normal sauf
qu'on ya ajouté un oeil de chexbres
dedans ou alors c'est jean marie le pen
qui s'est trop penché au dessus de la
question de bon sens
et pour terminer on prendrait bien un
petit café à brûler luwak en indonésien
les civettes qu'on voit à côté adore
avaler les graines de café yé je peux
sur koné cette histoire mais du fait
d'un système digestif peu performant et
ne dire que la pulpe est le fruit le
grain de café ressort de l'autre côté et
ça en fait un des cafés les plus chères
du monde et c'est amusant parce que
d'habitude c'est le café qui te donne un
bon transit alors ici c'est le transit
qui te donne un bon café
[Applaudissements]
est en fait le musée veut surtout faire
réfléchir au dégoût parce que ici
évidemment c'est pas un plat qui existe
c'est un une installation mais c'est le
nombre de substances chimiques qu'on va
retrouver dans une belle tranche de
jambon qui ne nous dégoûte rappaz donc
ça fait réfléchir j'ai un petit dernier
pour vous faire plaisir qui vient
d'afrique australe ce sont des chenilles
une source importante de protéines et
c'est surtout l'occasion de tomber
amoureux puisque plus on mange des
chenilles plus on a de chances d'avoir
des papillons dans le ventre je voulais
terminer mon les urnes à la direction
pour aller se rhabiller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus